come on down miami open for business
bubbling of activity
and excitement and optimism not just
because of the taxes but because of the
culture of innovation
[Music]
when the venture capitalist delianas
peruhov suggested on twitter last
december that the tech industry should
migrate from silicon valley to miami
mayor francis forest responded how can i
help he also set up a billboard in san
francisco
thinking of moving to miami dm me soros
is bold
rolled out the red carpet approach to
luring away silicon valley's tech elite
has gotten so much attention in part
because of how it contrasts with that of
california's ultra-left political class
take san diego assemblywoman lorena
gonzalez who's best known for her failed
effort to stop uber and lyft from using
contract labor in california to benefit
labor unions
gonzalez tweeted [ __ ] elon musk back in
may of 2020
message received replied musk in miami
mayor suarez has embraced musk's idea of
building a 30 million dollar tunnel for
electric vehicles to ease congestion
we have a unique opportunity to create a
signature project
not just for miami but for the world
[Music]
soros's publicity stunts including
fashioning himself an avid bitcoin
enthusiast have no doubt contributed to
the city's momentum but miami's greatest
advantage
isn't the vc heavyweights buying
mansions on the waterfront it's the
latino immigrants who don't garner
headlines or donate much to political
campaigns
but have brought with them grit and
talent largely wasted in the socialist
countries from which they fled
not to mention their cultural aversion
to big government liberalism and the
woke ideology now prevalent in the bay
area
miami's ascendance in the 21st century
hinges on whether it can continue to
fulfill its role as the greatest city in
latin america that just happens to be
located in the united states
nearly half a million cubans have come
to settle in miami-dade county
and these cubans seem to be in dade
county to stay
suarez himself is a scion of a
cuban-american political dynasty in
south florida his father javier
became miami's first cuban born mayor in
1985. the suarez clan probably wouldn't
be here at all if it weren't for the
communist dictator fidel castro who
deserves the most credit for miami
becoming a world-class city
political repression and the seizure of
private property under castro's rule
drove cubans to flee the island nation
and it was immigrants who transformed
the city from a sleepy backwater
into a latin american mecca florida's
population is climbing because of its
business-friendly climate the state is
second only to new hampshire and the
fraser institute's state ranking of
economic freedom the u.s
ranks sixth in the global rankings which
explains why latin american migrants
continue coming
venezuela whose citizens have escaped to
miami and mass in recent years
is that last at 162.
[Music]
miami is my home miami is the place
where i feel happy
my friends are here i married here my
parents lived here too
i went to school here cesar rajales
arrived in miami from colombia when he
was 19 with 80 dollars in his pocket
he says that his family fled colombia in
the 90s because they feared for their
lives
at the end of the 90s that was the peak
of the violence with the cartels and the
guerrillas
that i would say propel the
desire for many people to just leave the
country
colombia not only lacks a strong legal
system and rule of law
ranking 108th on the fraser institute's
freedom index in that category
it also ranked 93rd on the quality of
its currency
109th on tariffs and 69th on the size of
its regulatory state
so do you think there's there's any sort
of parallel between
latin americans escaping their countries
due to failed policies to come to miami
and people leaving silicon valley to
come to miami
definitely people is coming to florida
because here
with the decisions that we have been
taking lately and
at the state level had proven better
than the decisions that we
took in other states so definitely is a
connection there
california and the bay area in
particular in contrast
are a case study of the failure of big
government liberalism
i just don't understand how you create
success if you push out people that are
creating high-paying jobs that happened
that model happened in cuba
under communism and and it's it's just
the only equality that is created is
equal misery for all of its residents
that's part of our dna it's part of who
we are we believe in ourselves
we invest in ourselves and we want
government to take as
least of our money as possible and let
us be successful on our own but mayor
suarez is more marketing genius than
principled free market here
and there's always a risk that over time
the city government in miami will come
to more closely resemble san francisco's
it's becoming more and more difficult
for the market to provide the kind of
affordable
housing that is needed soares recently
oversaw the borrowing of 100 million
dollars for affordable housing
san francisco however borrowed 300
million both cities would better serve
their poorest residents by slashing red
tape
so that the private sector could provide
affordable housing more effectively
mayor suarez told axios that he wants to
triple the size of a city program that
gives companies financial incentives to
move to downtown miami confusing
capitalism with cronyism
suarez told reason that he considers
government handout schemes to be a form
of market competition
unfortunately what happens is other
areas subsidize and so we have to
compete with those areas so we want to
be competitive and that's part of being
in a capitalist society is competing we
want miami to be the capital of capital
from
new york and from los angeles and
silicon valley in san francisco
and that confluence of government we've
never seen merge anywhere in the history
of humanity it's not just for the good
of miami
suarez who's rumored to have
gubernatorial ambitions knows that
billionaire vcs are likely to become
future donors to his political campaigns
in january venture capitalist and former
facebook executive chamath palihapatiya
katsura is a quarter million dollar
check for his re-election campaign
for miami more important than becoming
home to a confluence of capital is that
it continues to be the center of a
confluence of immigrants from latin
america who have a bigger role to play
if the city is to succeed as a new tech
hub
is a venezuelan immigrant with a
profitable startup called ticketplate
which sells online passes to live
concerts streaming on the internet
his wife veronica ruiz del viso runs her
own successful digital marketing firm
[Music]
experience
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
doesn't have relationships with any of
the vc's mayor soares has his sights on
he's well connected within venezuela
which is an important factor in his
success
his website was quoted back in venezuela
and elnester's customer support team is
located there he estimates that for the
cost of one staffer in miami he can hire
six in venezuela
[Music]
says that for miami to become more of a
tech and business hub it needs to
develop networks that better serve
immigrant entrepreneurs
latino
[Music]
didn't come here primarily to grow their
businesses they left venezuela for the
same reason that cesar garcia's family
fled colombia
for stability and the rule of law
[Music]
i think there's a lot of people in miami
that are from a variety of different
backgrounds but a lot of them are from
current communist countries whether
venezuelan
nicaraguan cuban or have been
affected by it so yeah i think without a
doubt that there's a pervasive
sort of a pro-capitalistic bent and
mentality here
and that's part of what has appealed to
vcs like paypal co-founder peter thiel
and keith rabboy
conservative non-conformists who had
enough of san francisco's anti-business
animus and woke monoculture
i don't see the walk thing ever take all
the miami if you go out and you see
people you know half naked and having
fun like
you're kind of confronted with physical
reality in a way that will never
tran like work ideas will never
translate here it's not even anti book
there's just no concept of it
alex paris is a miami native a fiction
writer and a cultural commentator
who writes about how the outlook of the
american cognochenti doesn't translate
for miami latinos
especially when it comes to race and
politics all over there isn't with the
hispanic people there isn't
an affinity with wokeness is not like
if you were to interview my uncle and
tell him what that is he'd be like
this guy's pulling my leg and yeah if i
call my dad ladder next he tried to
fight me be like
what gesso i mean so that's basically
the way i see it like and
whenever i write these pieces people are
like nah he's you know he's lying i'm
like no it's just
i mean like i tell people that i'm a
writer i'm a cultural critic and they're
like man
what a sad man what is that a cultural
critic that's so and people think that's
like
speaking of miami no like it's just not
things that are
really relevant here one critic of
cancel culture who recently bought a
home in miami is bar stool founder dave
portnoy
you'd have to be a [ __ ] to pay new york
taxes he told the miami herald
but portnoy isn't moving his company
quite yet because he doesn't think his
employees could handle it
i don't know if some of us have the
willpower portnoy told the herald i
don't know what half the people in miami
do
it seems like few have to be at work the
next day after a night out we do
we're still normal guys built for cubes
working from nine to five
and if you've been up till 5am that's
hard to do that's probably true i mean
miami is
fast-paced but also very slow-paced like
people are fast-paced you know to go out
but then let's say you got to meet
somebody they might not you know show up
they go to a restaurant they might speak
spanish and that'll be fun
maybe from oh look somebody speaks
spanish that's funny how cute and then
let's see six months in do you think for
example there might be a culture clash
between silicon valley
culture you know very i don't know maybe
nerdy engineer culture
versus that miami party culture what i'm
really curious about mirrosaurus's pitch
is that it'll probably work for the
first four five six months
we're in march april weather's great
summer's not here yet hurricanes aren't
coming yet but i'll be curious
in four or five or six months how the
tech bros that are coming into town
are going to deal with the culture
because it's fun for three or four days
a weekend
but there is uh there is a wonkyish
nerdish element to that culture
that i'm not sure will translate to
miami i think some will love it but i
think those are the people that
maybe were from miami in a spiritual way
miami will only become a new and
improved silicon valley if it can
recreate the tech industry without the
left-wing nimbyism that made it
impossible for anyone except the
ultra-wealthy to find a place to live in
san francisco
or the wochism that's infected the ranks
of google and other tech giants
miami's best defense is the cultural
predisposition of immigrants from
countries like cuba
venezuela and colombia who understand
best of all the corrosive impact of big
government
we have to create ambiance for the
businesses
but it doesn't mean intervention it
doesn't mean using the taxpayers money
for corporate welfare so that's a fine
line
of saying the businesses and big
companies you know what relocate to my
state
we have a good economic rules here
there's a fine line between
saying that and one another saying come
here because we're gonna
build ex location for you to open your
business
that's corporate welfare that's using
taxpayers money and i don't think
that's fair